اذا ذكرت قياده الاركان الاوكرانيه ان
اعنف المعارك تدور حاليا عند مدينه باخموت
الشماليه مقاطعه
في شرق اوكرانيا في المقابل اعلنت وزاره
والدفاع الروسيه عن تدمير ثلاثه مراكز
قياده للقوات الاوكرانيه في دنيا
لمتابعه اخر التطورات الميدانيه معنى من
الكرامات الجزيره عامر لافي ومن موسكو
امين درغامي ابدا مع عامر اوكرانيا ما
الذي يقال عن المعارك في بخموت
نعم محمد يعني ربما كما ذكرت الجبهه
الشرقيه بشكل عام هي الجبهه الاسخن ان لم
تكن هي الجبهه المشتعله اشتعالا حقيقيا
نعم كل الاراضي الاوكرانيه مهدده تعلم
قياده الاركان اليوم تحدثت عن استهداف
مختلف المدن الاوكرانيه باثنين صاروخا وان
القياده القوات الجويه والدفاع الجوي
تمكنت من اسقاط فقط 16 من هذه الصواريخ
استهدفت كما ذكرنا مدن عديده في اوكرانيا
لكن من ناحيه القتال المباشر الجبهات
المفتوحه تتركز في هذه المنطقه في اقليم
دومباس وربما ان اسخن هذه المناطق هي طبعا
بكل تاكيد مدينه بخمود تلك المدينه التي
تحاول القوات الروسيه منذ اكثر من خمسه
اشهر ان تسيطر عليها المعارك هناك منذ
بدايه الحرب لكن التركيز على هذه المدينه
منذ خمسه اشهر الان القوات الروسيه تحاول
محمد الدخول الى المدينه
وتطويقها من كل جانب الان هناك ثلاث محاور
تحاول قوات روسيه منها هي المحور الشمالي
الشرقي والشرقي وايضا المحور الجنوبي
قياده الاركان تحدثت اليوم عن صبها للعديد
من الهجمات في هذه المحاور وتحدثت عن قصف
استهدفت اكثر من 15 قريه في محيط مخمود
وانها طبعا تتصدى لكل هذه محاولات التقدم
الاوكراني الروسيه لكن مصادرنا التي
تحدثنا معها من بخموت تتحدث عن اوضاع صعبه
عن تقدم روسي خصوصا على المحور الشمالي
الشرقي وبان القوات الروسيه قد تمكنت من
السيطره على اقراص ناهورا هذه المنطقه
التي يوجد فيها مرتفعات وكانت منطقه مميزه
وجيده جدا للدفاع عن المدينه لكن الان هي
تحت سيطره القوات الروسيه قوات الروسيه
ايضا تمكنت من الوصول الى الطريق
الاستراتيجي الواصل بين سلافيانس ومخمود
وهي الان تقطع هذا الطريق لكن هذا الوضع
غير مشابه في الجنوب وتحديدا عند الطريقه
الرئيسي الاخر الذي يربط قسطنطين ايفكا
بمخمود لم تتمكن الروسيه من الوصول الى
هذا الطريق بل ان القوات الاوكرانيه وانا
انقلون طبعا عن مصادرنا هناك تمكنت من دفع
القوات الروسيه التي كانت تقدمت في الايام
الماضيه الان هي تدفعها بعيدا عن هذا
الطريق الحديث طبعا عن تكبيد القوات
الروسيه خسائر كبيره على هذا المحور وهذا
طبعا سواء من التصريحات السياسيه
والعسكريه الاوكرانيه تتحدث عن ارسال
تعزيزات بشكل مستمر وعن جنود تم تاهيلهم
على عجل وارسالهم الى هذه الجبهه وبالتالي
هناك خسائر كبيره في صفوف هؤلاء الجنود
غير المدربين على حسب وصف القياده
العسكريه الاوكرانيه امين اذا كيف تدير
وتسير
روسيا هذا التقدم ايضا بمشاركته فاغنر
محمد يبدو ان الجيش الروسي اخذ استراتيجيه
ثابته خلال الاشهر الاخيره هذه
الاستراتيجيه خاصه طبعا في محور اقليم
دومباس وتحديدا الى صحه تعبير حول مدينه
بخموت هذه الاستراتيجيه تقوم على التحرك
البطيء والدفع
بمجموعات قتاليه صغيره ومحاوله تطويق
تجمعات القوات الاوكرانيه تطويق البلدات
والمدن وقطع طرق الامداد وذلك على ما يبدو
لتجنب وقوع خسائر في صفوف القوات الروسيه
الاعتماد في محور بخموت وطبعا البلدات
المحيطه بالسوليدار على قوات فاجنر التي
تعد قوات اقتحام بالدرجه الاولى وطبعا
هناك
تكثيف للقصفه المدفعي والصاروخي على مواقع
الجيش الاوكراني هذه استراتيجيه يبدو انها
بدات تعطي يعني نتائج جيده بالنسبه للجيش
الروسي بعد السيطره طبعا على سوليدار وعلى
مدن وبلدات هامه جدا في محور بخموت والان
الحديث عن التطويق الكامل الوشيك لمدينه
بخموت في غضون شهر كما توقع اليوم مؤسس
هذه الشركه
طبعا كل هذا ياتي بتزامن مع مواصله
استهداف العمق الاوكراني
بالصواريخ بعيده المدى بالطائرات المسيره
بين الفينه والاخرى والاستهداف واضح انه
يتم او يركز بدرجه الاولى على المنشات
البنيه التحتيه الطاقه بدرجه الاولى
المقر القياده العسكريه الاوكرانيه في عدد
من المقاطعات وايضا
خطوط سكك الحديديه في محاوله على ما يبدو
او اعاقه على الاقل الوصول الامدادات
العسكريه
للجبهه الشرقيه هناك حيث القوات
الاوكرانيه طبعا كل هذا ياتي وسط تصريحات
اليوم صدرت على لسان رئيس جمهوريه الموالي
لروسيا الذي اكد ان القوات الروسيه باتت
تسيطر على كل المرتفعات الرئيسيه حول
مدينه باخموت ماذا يعني ذلك يعني بان
المدينه ناريا باتت تقريبا شبه مطوقه من
كل
الجهات
وهناك ايضا تحرك عسكري في المحور الجنوبي
تحديدا في اوجليدار هذا ليس وليد اليوم بل
منذ تقريبا نحو شهر حيث تحاول القوات
الروسيه في شكل
القوات التابعه للمنطقه الشرقيه في روسيا
للدخول الى هذه المدينه التي لم يشهد
محورها اي تغير ميداني منذ نصف سنه تقريبا
وهناك على ما يبدو محاولات لتحريك هذه
الجبهه ايضا
لك اشكر ايضا عامر لا في شكرا جزيلا لكما